la contraception est un droit chacun
doit pouvoir s'informer et choisir en
connaissance de cause
yvette roudy le ministre des droits de
la femme ainsi réaffirmé aujourd'hui la
volonté du gouvernement de poursuivre la
campagne nationale d'information sur la
contraception
après une première vague d' annonce que
vous avez pu voir la télévision ce sont
maintenant des messages chanter qui
seront diffusées dès demain sur
certaines radios pour continuer à
sensibiliser l'opinion sur un problème
et sur des droits encore mal perçus en
82 13 ans après la légalisation de la
contraception et huit ans après son
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
à peine un tiers des femmes utilisent un
moyen contraceptif a appelé vendredi le
pourcentage est encore plus faible chez
les adolescentes
si 70% de jeunes de moins de 18 ans ont
déjà eu des relations sexuelles 15%
seulement connaissent les contraceptifs
affirme la revue par an sur la base d'un
sondage de l'ifop
la nouvelle campagne pour la
contraception va donc viser entre autres
les lycées et les collèges
même si beaucoup organise déjà des cours
sur la question
l'enquète de civils marion et robert
rosier à maisons alfort
ils ont 16 ou 17 ans issus de familles
d'ouvriers ou d'employés
ils sont élèves du lycée d'enseignement
professionnel de maisons alfort
ils ont suivi quelques cours sur la
contraception ils souhaitent en savoir
davantage on a parlé des de certains
moyens mais simplement s'envoler 3 par
exemple
quel est le moyen d'une connexion pas
qu'ils avaient appris la en classe
fab les moyens certains moyens prenait
pour les femmes enfants on les a survolé
en avant par exemple
non je pense au stérilet l'aviez jamais
entendu parler
pouvez vous me dire comment
l'information sur la sexualité circuler
avancée qui va très mal on n'en parlait
pas du tout entre garçons vous ne
parliez pas sinon ça circule très mal on
peut pas en parler beaucoup beaucoup
parce que sa dérive d'autres choses qui
sont pas belles à entendre dans les
écoles par exemple et si qui connaissait
pas ces trucs là sont retrouvés à son
enceinte soit avec des gros problèmes de
famille où il agace tout leur dis pas ça
gâche 6h20 je peux te donner un élément
important qui était qui a été dit dans
la classe de sandrine c'est une fille
qui s'est retrouvée enceinte en
troisième qui n'avait pas eu d'éléments
dont information sexuelle qui s'est
retrouvée enceinte et qui n'a même pas
pu dire ni à ses parents ni à ses
enseignants qu'elle était enceinte
quelle a été la réaction de vos parents
lorsqu'ils ont su que vous aviez des
courses la contraception lycée disons
que j'en aurai sa part les uns genève
marqué ce que ces jeunes là sont
représentatifs des jeunes en général
plus ou moins bien informés sur la
contraception et c'est effectivement des
jeunes qui ont réellement besoin d'une
information pour l'utiliser très vite
que finalement dans
dans leur vie qui sera rapidement ans on
l'espère du moins active c'est vrai que
souvent ils sont bloqués ils ont du mal
à parler de même parler leur vécu et
s'il me semble très important d'aborder
ce thème
donc de la contraception de les mettre
en confiance de pouvoir discuter avec
eux et aussi de leur apporter des
informations très précises et surtout de
peut-être encore plus de gommer toutes
les choses fausses que ils ont pu qu'ils
ont pu entendre dans la famille ou dans
la rue parce que souvent l'éducation
sexuelle s'est fait pratiquement est
théoriquement je dirais dans la rue